if you're shopping for a car be prepared
for a sticker shock
prices are at a record level so let's
break this down for you
talking about first about new cars the
average cost of a new car
has now topped 40 000 and used cars
are up nearly 30 percent in the last
year carter evans tells us that the main
reason
is a shortage in computer chips
you can actually put the seats down when
nina and ziska went shopping recently
for a new car
there were a few options and no deals
how much more did you spend than you
wanted to
i probably am spending probably closer
to a hundred dollars more a month than i
wanted to she was hoping to lease the
same model volkswagen jetta that her
brother got
nine months ago for 250 a month she was
quoted
3 15 26 higher
for the same car for the same exact car
it's absolutely nuts right now if you
want to buy a new car
auto industry analyst ed kim says the
computer chip shortage
is to blame so you're not getting any
big discounts on cars oh god no
i would say you're pretty lucky if
you're just paying msrp
during the pandemic u.s automakers
temporarily closed factories and
canceled orders for computer chips amid
plunging sales
so chip makers focused instead on making
smaller chips for electronics like
refrigerators tvs
phones and laptops which are all in high
demand now
once you adapt your supply chain to to
something else
it takes a while to go back i struggle
to see things
going back to what they were you know
for another i would say
six to nine months in the meantime some
automakers are storing
unfinished vehicles ford says it's
putting the brakes on production at some
factories this summer
the company anticipates producing more
than a million
fewer vehicles this year many are now
turning to used vehicles
driving prices up 30 percent in may with
some models reselling for more than they
did when they were new
what advice would you give to someone
who needs to buy a car in the next six
months
well if at all possible wait if you've
got a used car to sell
now is a wonderful time to sell it as
long as you don't have to buy one to
replace it
carter evans cbs news los angeles
well if you must buy now experts say the
best prices are on sedans because get
this
they are less popular